drei mauer bauen eine mauer a und b
viren in zwang in zwölf tagen fertig b
und c in 20 a und c im 15
wann ist die arbeit durch alle drei
männer fertig gestellt hat euch der
lehrer kein tipp gegeben
da warst du selbst nicht und sei dann
doch nicht fragt ja das ist ganz einfach
du musst einfach nur nur nur warten bis
sein vater nach hause kommt
er hat doch so was studiert ich weiß
schon wie das letzte schon wieder zehn
minuten her gezogen und ihr ableben
mauer oder was tui wird die jury die
schwierige zeit los damit die ganzen
hanswurst der straße weg sein und damit
meine ich nicht die schüler da ist es
mir dass bush wie lange das die mauer
dort über den hunger ist kursen um punkt
6 ist das essen fertig erst die
hausaufgaben und dann gehts essen nicht
halb sechs nicht bei viertel 6.6 corssen
geleckt mich war das ein scheißtag im
büro das ist mit dem essen doch kosten
und sexistisch essen haben dich es gibt
ja gleich essen aber zuerst müssen wir
uns um die hausaufgaben von der su sie
kümmern weiß doch die steht in mathe wie
der ochs vor dem berg das ist ein
riesenberg und davor steht er ziemlich
dummer ochs jetzt sage mir was man da
haben also 3 maurer bauen eine mauer und
maurer brauchen dafür zwölf yahoos artig
der feine herr v ingenieur nimmt die
sache in die hand der hat noch nie eine
kelle in der hand kraft aber jetzt wäre
dort vorne aufgemerkt als zehnter des
kunden gelangt sind doch ich weiß dass
ich war doch 50 jahre lang auf dem bau
ja das ist ja so einfach das kann ja
fünfjährige lösen
hill 4 doch sonst kommen wir nie zum
essen das muss doch selber auskennt ist
schließlich was lerne aber die mama
hälfte etwas anders die hat ja auch
keine ahnung
bei der letzten hause wo der papa hat
habe ich einst exact an sex das haben
wir nicht verdient
der lehrer auf zeit aber ich möchte den
hunde gibt es nicht es gibt nämlich
genau drei arten von menschen die wie
zählen können und die die nicht zählen
können also passiv steigert ist einmal
so vor das ist maurer und das ist meine
basis der vollkommen falsche ansatz ist
kommt doch darauf an wer ist der maurer
b wer ist ist wien ist so paris wieder
hornbacher sieht mit dem hobby auf der
baustelle gabe bekommt sie sowieso
vergessen und zu trocken war so blöd
wieder mal nur so martina zur klever
später hätte überhaupt paroli es geht um
zeit und seit einstein wissen wir dass
zeit relativ ist ein stein einstein
einstein ist aber keine mauer er dies
ist ein steigendes co2 stein dreistein
vier statt fünf stein das ist ein bauer
auf meinem tisch brauchst du keine mauer
niemand hat die absicht eine mauer zu
bauen
irgendwo habe ich schon mal hier
irgendwo richtig gehandelt und lassen
dich lieb jetzt hast du immer steht ist
schon unglaublich
5 nicht wenn du nach denkst ich hoffe
dass dieser bug schießen also beide
wirkliches gefühl es geht bei und
dollhouse jobs doch zehn tage
wir müssen bloß aber den
kostenvoranschlag mannschaft war sehr
ruhig es gibt keinen kostenvoranschlag
froscon kostenvoranschlag man allerdings
sowieso ab schießt ja aber du siehst du
in unserer zeit ist gibt keine
ehrlichkeit mehr und keine pünktlichkeit
punkt 6 unter noch ein einziges mal
vergessen anfängst dann kannst du heim
fahren und dir eine dose spielbar machen
inkorporiert zu den hundert menschen
jedoch immer nur warten zehn tage 10
tage brauchen maurer a b und c um die
mauer zu errichten
ich bin der größte ich bin das schönste
ich bin begrüßte die weihnachtlichen aus
dem internet nachgelesen
wir haben das früher als auswendig
lernen müssen alles ja und es braucht so
und wird so wirke sie endlich die
nächste aufgabe
zwei züge verlassen mit gleicher
geschwindigkeit die städte nürnberg und
regensburg mama
[Applaus]